looking at True Grit now was there
anything about I don't know just the way
that set was run the people that you
were working with anything at all that
makes you think when you look back on it
thank God I had that first big Hollywood
experience on that film with them
everything about it I can't even begin
to tell you I I it's it's so wild that
that was my first legitimate experience
because it was all around I mean I want
to say just who's so wonderful it was so
seamless and so fun I mean there were
just it was a bunch of people who really
cared and were so just equally as
passionate about one thing and one thing
only and that was the art and and making
this the best it could be and you know
going home to their families every night
and and coming back to work and having
the most fun but taking it you know
seriously enough and it just was it was
just an amazing dynamic it was always
the the you know tone and the vibe was
always just so positive and calm and
just a wonderful work environment to be
and I I realized how lucky it's been ten
years and I've done quite a few I've
been on quite a few sets since then that
are not necessarily like that and it's
it's really a blessing when you get an
amazing group of people like that and it
just runs seamlessly is there anything
in particular that you kind of absorbed
from your experience making that that
you especially as a leader now because
it's important to be number one on the
call sheet and help set the tone that
you've absorbed from them and brought to
your own sets now 100% I I feel like
I definitely do feel like with with
every job I do there is some points that
I feel whether it's something I'm doing
something I'm feeling something I'm
thinking the way something is going down
I true drink pops back into my mind and
there's always a moment from that that I
feel either influenced the way I am now
or how I you know handle certain
situations I don't know I do I do feel
like I constantly refer back to that
experience and try and pull on whatever
it was that I learned and held on to
because it was great
I always like to ask about you know
bumps in the road and how you overcame
them and I brought this up with ASA as
well I am a huge Enders game fan and I
don't leave him one of my favorites that
visits I love the book and I thought the
adaptation was great and you know it
upset me a good deal when that didn't
take off as I was hoping it would so
from your perspective especially given
the fact that that was one of your very
first you know potential franchise
starters and how was it kind of you know
dealing with that bit of disappointment
when it didn't take off and form spawn
more films you know it's always so like
weird when you hear that it's gonna be
something it's gonna be big it's gonna
be here it's gonna go there it's gonna
be all these things and and then when
it's not that you feel like you have
failed one thing I have realized is you
know I guess here's the thing I guess I
kind of learned or picked up on when
making True Grit
you know we we shot that film and it
came out the same here it was a very
quick turnaround regardless of what it
was and it obviously ran the awards
circuit and all of that and not once
during the making of that film was
anything said about awards or you know a
wide release or what all of these terms
that are thrown around on as far as this
thing's gonna be huge you know
and maybe there was and I just wasn't
aware of it but it basically what I'm
getting at is is for me of course you
always hope that it's gonna be something
earth-shattering and unbelievable and a
moment of history it's not always about
that it's never really been about that
for me I feel very lucky that I do feel
like the projects I have done the
majority of them have been seen by the
right people and I just feel very
fortunate for that well yeah I mean it's
it's a tough thing to I mean I remember
when I did regret everybody told me your
life's about to change like you're not
gonna be able to walk out so all this
[ __ ] and I was just like none of that
none of that no that it's not I mean you
do the work because you love it and
whoever sees it sees it and I think I've
also had to accept that there becomes a
time where it's out of my hands and you
know I always used to kind of hang on to
those things like I said that doesn't
happen at all suddenly it was my
performance or I failed or it was me or
whatever but you know it comes a point
where you know it's out of your hands